à travers les époques les dangers qu en
aventure les appels
et encore elle nous sommes sur le
titanic enfin quand je dis nous je parle
pas de vous de moi je pense billy elliot
le lapin thomas et thomas et oui il ya
notamment celui qu'on connaît et au
match vient d'un futur indescriptible
ils doivent empêcher un mystérieux
personnage de modifier le temps et j'ai
une petite théorie de qui ça peut-être
dû à la faux
vite trouver ce type qui veut modifier
le temps et avant que le titanic coule
c'est possible tomber mais on est dans
un film on va croiser jack et rose n'est
pas beaucoup plus intelligent dans le
futur non
jack et rose il existe pas fait par
contre ledit gagnant qu'on apprenne
aujourd'hui joël votre connaisseur de
bord nous avons une annonce vocale sur
la brochure du voyage nous vous avions
promis un passage au milieu des icebergs
malheureusement nous allons te voir
annuler sa collectivement une personne
très bien attentionnés a prévenu notre
capitaine de navire des risques de cette
magnifique ballade milieu des icebergs a
pas en se basant sur une très très bonne
documentation notamment à vidéogrammes
documenter un deux trois heures avec une
chanson qui reste inquiète puisque les
mois pour ce changement de dernière
minute mais la sécurité c'est important
surtout quand on manque de bateaux de
sauvetage en voyage à tous c'est très
régulières de la part de ces personnes
mais le voilà c'est lui le méchant veut
empêcher le titanic de couler c'est ça
il est en train de modifier le temps je
le sens prêt je crois que sur le
désintègre regarder l'autre disparaître
comme dans autant le futur
malheureusement aussi à vous couper tout
ça
s'il a peint le petit lapin a disparu
merde ça veut dire que le temps est
modifié non non il va réapparaître mais
pour ça on doit remettre le temps comme
il l'était et et empêcher le méchant de
sauver le titanic vient rien de méchant
à sauver le titanic papa a été clair il
faut laisser le temps intact c'est le
titanic ne coule pas ça va créer
d'importants changements qui vont nous
mener à l'apocalypse est nommé arrête de
l'appeler papa c'est gênant et le mas
conçu et je suis un humain je suis comme
son fils pourquoi vouloir empêcher le
titanic du coup les comprends rien vous
voulez cool le titanic mais t'inquiète
pas jack et rose existe pas on est dans
un film
les gens vont pas vraiment mourir oui
voilà on va dire ça il faut refaire la
fin du film
mais comment faire exactement le même
tronçon iceberg un trou ne suffira pas
l'iceberg avait traversé plusieurs
niveaux pour faire sombrer le bateau
raison elliott
comment faire plusieurs trous à
plusieurs niveaux qu'on peut utiliser
mon laser si j'ai de la lumière
bano nous intéresse à une lumière est
pas un laser pour donc vous parler
j'ai fabriqué des bombes avec du savon
et différents produits ménage pas moi
pendant vous parliez j'ai fait semblant
de comprendre la situation mais thomas
comment tu sait fabriquer des bombes
mon époque si tu sait pas fabriquer une
bombe
un homme 1 ça fait envie voici un plan
en 3d holographique de l'impact de
l'iceberg sur le titanic
vous voyez longtemps ouais il en taille
traverse la cote jeunes taille ou sa du
hentai voilà où poser les bombes pour
recréer l'incident j'vois pas tentacules
bon voilà le plan on va se diviser en
trois groupes
elliott tu vas dans la salle des
machines les thomas vous allez en
seconde classe
moi je vais en première classe on place
les explosifs on se retrouve sur le pont
on fait tout péter en même temps et au
titanic pias enfin quelque chose
d'amusant dans ma vie de souffrance oui
oui mais il y at on doit vraiment tuer
des innocents peu importe ils sont déjà
décédées dans notre époque mais quand
même il suffirait de rien faire et
détaille jean survivrait je te rappelle
que c'est le plan d'un échange il ya
peut être un tueur d'enfants parmi ceux
qui sont morts sur le titanic je
comprends rien vous dilemme si on ne
fait pas couler le titanic
le temps sera modifié le lapin ne
viendra plus nous chercher on restera
coincé en 1912 pour toujours mais tu as
raison c'est parti pour l'opération
bah titanic quel rinne que des
machines sans armes
voilà cet emplacement semble parfait
pour l'explosif et fait quoi ici tu
attends toi à l'aise devant les
collégiens
bonjour j'ai redit je suis à l'humain
attribué à la profession de mécanicien
tout comme vous n'ont pas je vous ai
jamais vu un veau yeux sont peut-être
défaillant je travaille ici depuis un
million de son 9600 secondes soit deux
semaines aux excuses et moi mon grave en
ce moment je suis plus très attentif
ce métier me rend fou ma femme ne le
reconnaît plus elle dit que je viens
robots sans émotion les femmes je vous
jure avec leurs émotions sinusoïdale on
ne peut pas vivre avec mais on ne peut
pas vivre sans
c'est ce que je pense en tant qu'humain
de sexe masculin du début du xxème ou
deux raisons en sont restées des
machines vendues à têtu manque de
contact avec le reste du groupe au staff
c'est une histoire très divertissante
qu'est-ce que je rigole j'ai du travail
maintenant je dois surveiller la
pression du turbine alternatif qui
alimente les deux hélices là tu es dans
la totale selon wikipedia pourvoira
désolé collègues nous avons pts et 10 à
la personne ne comprend je suis une
machine depuis dans ce monde qui n'a
plus de sens
[Musique]
qu'est ce que ça doit toujours bienvenu
messieurs vous aussi vous avez mis
toutes vos économies dans ce voyage pour
tenter une nouvelle vision continent
américain
ouais ouais c'est ça venez vous amuser
avec nous on n'a plus d'argent
ici la nourriture n'est pas bonne et la
plupart d'entre nous tombent malades
on a des rêves plein la tête des ans et
que l'arrivée sans la chance quand bien
vite être comme ça il l'a pas vu leurs
revenus
thomas du passé je vais faire diversion
grâce à ton corps frêle je te ferai un
passage au milieu de la foule pour
rejoindre la paroisse du fonds placé la
bombe et fais moi un signe discret que
ses mensonges ou forme tellement une
équipe de choc
j'y vais qu'est ce qu'on s'amuse
regardez mes muscles
[Musique]
ah excusez moi pardon désolé désolé
dans ce petit bébé moi
à
j'ai mis la bombe chose que c'est bon
j'ai placé la bombe à stx est vivante
astique touch me miba qui s'est mise à
mister o matic brusquement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les chocs et m heureusement qu'on a
sacré boulot juqu'au parle
j'espère qu'il est censé nous donne ce
qui n'est riche pas faire de l'argent et
dire qu'il ya des gens qui ont plus un
sou juste sous les 10 simplement pour
vous dire que votre robe est ravissante
merci excusez moi mais je suis attendu
je me présente
giuly à florence schifrin mon mari est à
la tête de la wsl compagnie et vous avec
qui elle l'honneur de discuter iris
où est votre nom de famille époux sûr de
ne pas vous être trompé d'étagé sécurité
je crois qu'une pomme offerte revenant
de preto iris vianney de preto mon mari
dirige la pnl compagnie ou là excusez
moi vraiment je suis confuse j'ai cru un
instant que vous n'étiez pas comme nous
vous voulez dire riche en voilà et qui
rejoignent et vous je peux vous aider à
retrouver cette personne faisait maître
gims de la vega je ne connais pas cet
avocat elle a souhaité vous un macarons
à la framboise ou encore un éclair à la
piste en écoute et je vais être franche
je ne suis pas très à l'aise avec tout
ces abondance ne trouvez vous pas que
vos privilèges sont la source des plus
hauts
rim et d'amandes notre chef pâtissier à
travailler dans les endroits les plus
prestigieux du secondeur vous parliez du
fait que nous soyons riches
non mais oubliez vous pouvez me rendre
un service
mais bien sûr entrepris voici un paquet
posé le contre la paroi là bas où c'est
lourd c'est lourd et ça fait tic-tac
je vois une montre de luxe que vous
allez offrir à maître gims de la vega
non ne me dit rien comptez sur moi oui
c'est à merci ma beauté je dois filer je
vous reprends juste quelques éclairs
c'est bon les explosifs sans place
parfaitement j'ai rempli ma tâche qu'est
ce que j'entends c'est chagué c'est
assez long a expliqué vasily rice a plu
sur le détonateur s'est coulé le bateau
elle attendait attendez on est sur le
bateau il va couler et loue le la pop
genou récupérer nous ici revient pas je
ne sais pas iris c'est toi qui nous a
dit qu'il reviendrait si on rétablissait
le temps la wii mais j'ai dit ça comme
ça vous marque attendre je vends à la
fin du film
j'adore la chanson du générique de
mouassa
[Musique]
bonjour toujours qu elle le japon un
petit problème mais rebecca n'a pas de
panique
à l'attention des pauvres riches que
dans ma chambre à tout va bien merci
beaucoup je voudrais tombe la neige dès
qu'un autre chose qu'à soit à votre
disposition la mission est réussie mais
il est apparu exactement comme j'avais
annoncé vous avez attrapé le méchant non
on n'a pas eu le temps de l'approché qu
il ya un méchant letter chimie a capté
une nouvelle modification dans le temps
affluence en 15/100 3c doit être lui
excuse moi m'ont dit shi florence à à
florence tu dis pas je vais à le
coiffeur s'est tant que need ali alors
on dit chez florence en italie
bon on y va on va l'attraper temporal
isation d'en annoncer votre allégation
alors voilà ma théorie vous en faites ce
que vous voulez le mec qui modifie le
temps c'est adolf hitler est sorti de la
faille j'ai pas comment il veut casser
une temps parce qu'ils en somme
non pas c'est quoi bah dites moi dans
les commentaires moi je les lis tout 5
contre moissy prix
il a pris la grosse tête merci d'avoir
écouté et à la semaine prochaine pour le
troisième épisode de l'épopée temporel